hey wassup guys my name is the churner
and welcome to episode 91 of game
programming okay so today we're gonna
talk about animation for our new AI
dummy guy so right now he's not animated
again and it's probably gonna make um oh
well animation is not the other thing
we're gonna talk about well now also
talk about how to how to actually move
him obviously and you guys could
probably get that out but hey I should
probably show it just in guys right now
he actually looks like a like a carpet
because look at this like he's
completely flat on the ground here on
akuze walk over I mean it's actually
really funny but anyway so we
essentially want to make him um animate
it so we have made an animators bright
here in fact you know what we're gonna
do this is completely improvised I just
decided to do this now because it's a
probably a good idea instead of having
him have the same skin as the player
just for now at least
having the same sprite as the player
let's make him have the other King
Jonah's bright because I'm at least
they'll basically differ differ him from
from what we look like right now so I'm
going to go into our workspace into our
game programming rain here we are in
resources we have a folder called
textures and a folder called spreadsheet
yeah and in sprite shape we've got this
plague guy so let's open the sprite
sheet in in paint.net alright there it
is and all I'm gonna do here is just
basically copy this guy so if I hit s
and then select this area here or of
course if you don't want to hit s there
is this tools palette here you can
actually just select the selecting thing
which is the top left icon here select
the area here and control say that file
new it should automatically are set the
size to what your selection area which
was 96 by 96 of course because each of
these sprites is 32 pixels wide and high
and there were three of them hit OK
control V there we go perfect okay so
basically what we've done right now is
essentially the same thing as our player
has now now we don't have a third column
oh sorry a fourth column here because um
we decided to actually use off the flip
I guess operation to flip him that's
cool okay buddy not really necessary but
I don't know if I should um well let's
actually let's actually screw that okay
the flipping squad you guys how how you
want how you can do that if you want to
I'm not gonna do it that way okay I'm
actually just gonna model it the same
way as this so we have going down first
then going up then left then right so up
sorry down up left right okay so that's
up right now so let's just change this
across okay left alright so right is the
last one let me just um so this is why I
created grids are good so let's maybe
make a new layer here just just for now
and I'm gonna go ahead and go image
sorry on image it effects grid and I'm
just going to make it 32 by 32 here Oh
yep it's a yep
now foreground only head okay now we
have this grid thing here which is very
useful because it'll allow us to
actually select um just the row here
just a column here and let's just cut
that oops wrong layer cut that and paste
it I could have just moved it couldn't I
I am really clasp on here right over
here which is here I believe yes yep
right there
okay I'm gonna hit enter on that so and
then I'm going to move this up to the
second one so I am to move move him over
here to the second one I think that's
that's right there and then I'm of
course the top one I want to move around
so I'm but basically just arranging him
the same way that our other one was this
glorious King Jenna and my other one I
mean the the updated place right that we
made okay so now what we need to do is
replace this one with this this second
sorry
third row here with um with him going
the other way which is surprisingly left
so copy and paste that and then just um
drag here and it'll have to be I think
like that
I look good there's like that right
I guess for that let's um let's oh we
copied him with white space as well oh I
think that's not moved correctly all
right doesn't matter that is 32 so I
guess we should be up to here there we
go
that's right okay and then we can of
course just delete this layer of the
gridlines and you can see that we did
screw up here somehow
and unfortunately 100 know where that's
all right we'll assume that's right and
we'll just uh quickly grab this color
and paste it into here okay cool so now
what we've done is we've actually made
this spreadsheet be the same as as this
spreadsheet again but obviously with a
different sprite so let's save that and
we'll call this uh dummy
now we'll call this King Chan oh he
needs a real name and we'll just save it
in sheets okay so now that we've done
that let's use our um our awesome
animated sprite class here to make that
so insensate what are that's bright
shade sorry in spread shape we've got
these uh this what am i doing player
yeah whoops let's actually move we don't
need this anymore do we
oh hang on what's that drawing from oh
that's the players pratchet play a shape
oh so we're not using this anymore are
we to play a down stuff that shouldn't
be existing anymore because we've got an
atom a sprite so let's get rid of that
in Thailand you can see it does give us
errors let's see in animate okay it
looks like we do need oh I see oh yeah
of course
sorry I just forgot how I am made this
whoops
don't delete that make a new one over
here and use bright Shadia called um
here's right because we made the whole
sprite sub splashy thing called dummy
and of course this will draw in a drawer
in from Qing China Lion King sure know
the PNG and it will be the same
resolution of course and what I want to
do now is exactly the same right because
we made the sheet the same so we can
just copy and paste this and of course
changeable of this dummy all this player
sprite shade here - just dummy just like
that okay and then of course change that
to dummy left dummy right acid up dummy
up dummy down whatever dummy right and
that should out that should work out
fine okay so now what we need to do is
the quick way of doing this is probably
going into player and just simply
copying and pasting all this animators
bright stuff into our new dummy class
here that we made yesterday in episode
90 of game programming and of course
I'll just change this to be a dummy damn
and dummy whoops didn't copy that dummy
up dummy left and dummy right all right
and of course I'll go back to play let
me just close everything here whoops
I meant to close all but this but
doesn't matter I've been playing over
dumb player and dummy here from player
I'm just gonna take well first of all we
should set the sprite to be a default
one so instead of dummy forward just set
it to so I set of player forward will
set it to dummy chord which does not
exist let's see
didn't I call it that what did I call it
oh we make surprise for that that's fine
we'll set the sprite for dummy to be mmm
think check I think probably just one of
these right so down okay missus
particles down by default I hope that
works let's go back into play here and
we've got this whole warping stuff
so if input up let's just copy all this
over here this is all our movement code
okay we could make an intermediate class
that actually already has this stuff in
fact I'm thinking I might do it that way
of course we don't need it put that up
we just need a gauge which direction is
going in so I'll just may come up
probably oh we could just do um we could
make a quick enumeration to deal with
that thought oh probably will do that so
private a nom Direction here and we'll
just have off down oops
up down freaking hell up down left right
I'm protists okay up down left right I
will quickly make a I don't know why I
capitalized that you like a boss here
so private direction called just the I
are in fact I'm thinking I might just
cut and paste this thing into our mob
class just because it does apply to all
mobs so we'll make it protected of
course alright so that we can be able
make make them both protected alright so
I got this this this is a direction here
as well will cut that direction and just
because it's like 0 1 2 3 is that's how
I roll usually with direction but a lot
of you guys were saying that oh it's
hard I were just complaining being like
oh I don't know what it means well you
should make any beam eration so I will
remember an enumeration is the same as
integers essentially the data in an in
an enumeration is stored as an integer
so in terms of performance and stuff it
should be relatively the same I haven't
done extensive testing on that so don't
quote me on that but hey okay what's
going on with this uh these errors here
Direction dot up all right okay no it's
good so every set the direction here and
I think up here what's the deal yeah
dummy Direction else one thought that
because it's we moved in here okay so
wait so all this stuff now if Direction
equals Direction up sorry that's wrong
if we are moving up then I'll hang on
how do we know okay that's fine so if
Direction dot up if Direction equals
directional up then do that so this
sprite now I think that's just called
annum sprite isn't it
so private how do we do it in player
let's take a look here so we had an
animator sprite here okay cool so we'll
make it private animated sprite called
sprite um sorry which cut off annum and
annum sprite we'll set it equal to down
to begin with and that will get rid of
those errors now this wire - - stuff
let's quickly make a int X a and
why okay make sure that the both set to
zero cut I do like dividing them into
separate lines cuz that's how I roll and
input up left again will just change its
direction um down and we'll change this
to direction left and this of course to
direction right this episode is much
longer than I intended for it to be but
that's alright
rewriting this code is probably better
okay so um and then we make a move by
whatever text anyway is okay
that's probably I'm just realizing it's
probably wrong because um y and X I
should definitely shouldn't be here but
that's alright okay that should in fact
yeah that's completely wrong what am i
doing um the direction up then there's
no point in us doing this in fact this
is if I care let's um let's let's
restructure this sorry okay I am sorry
for wasting a bit of your time let's get
rid of all these y IX A's stuff and we
will move this everywhere though this
direction thing so direction I think
this was right this was yeah left
obviously and this was down okay so what
we want to say is basically if X a is
greater than 0 or if it's less than 0 so
this should be Y so if Y a is greater
than 0 but only down obviously but if Y
is less than 0 we're going up and the
same thing here right so if X a is to go
left if X a is less than 0 we're going
left
if however X a is greater than 0 we are
going right ok so all we need to do now
is that a method um for X a and Y and I
will move our don't move our guy because
we have this move method here of course
and walking will be true ok so just like
we did in player we had this thing here
that said if walking and let's animate
sprite else set it to frame 0 right so
again if the player is walking then lets
or if this mob is walking then make sure
that we actually animate him right
because we want his legs to move so Anam
spri optic
else if he's not walking if he's just
standing still we clearly don't want to
remove his legs so else we can set an 'm
sprite dot frame set frame to zero
because that'll that that won't leave
him mid walk like that'll actually set
him to just stand up straight
instead of having his leg like in the
air and that that should be a route
about it so let's just run this and see
if it crashes okay did crash that was a
good prediction that China not want
except refer this oh why is there a null
pointer children this is in screen okay
it looks like sprites probably now right
nor really what's null here so sprites
not know what earth is no okay no only
be pixels or sprite so let's go back
into regions anything you know okay
let's go back and set sprite us I mean
we reliably know he's not and also it's
bright dot flower
it's be funny okay that's for craft
interesting okay so what the hell is
alright next out of bounds what am I
getting all pointer from that's fine
let's get rid of them flower here those
nice little fix that okay so we still
getting a null oh it is no so it's null
and a right X at a balanced section once
a double arrow okay let's um the way we
think stupid player was at we set it to
a sprite that we reliably knew was the
default special player so let's also
make a sprite defaults bright for the UM
for a guy here so let's make let's make
a public static sprite called just dummy
and we'll set it equal to new sprite and
of course we will use just basically
zero zero what else we need we need size
as well so 32 32 0 0 out of sprite sheet
dots
dummy yeah that's it
in fact beginners use dummy down better
near to use such an extravagant
spreadsheet
yeah all right this is our default dummy
sprite from sprite so it's bright dot
dummy okay and if we launch that we
should not get the error anymore oh we
got another hour
great okay man this sprite stuff is not
fun now as to
sighs why is it doing sighs see I don't
know why but I just felt this idea at
the beginning to just assume that we're
gonna have square spreadsheets like I
don't know what I was smoking but um
yeah it wasn't right so sheet dot is it
get with oh we don't have that well it's
worth of capital I was gonna say no no
it'd be weird let's see if that worked
okay and yeah we do have a default thing
here I guess that did work make sure we
define a default sprite I just in case
these spreadsheets of the animators
brushes haven't been instantiated or
initialized yet okay so cool now that
we've got that covered let's go to mob
here let's just try moving him okay so
what I want to do for that is I'll
launch this right over here and I'm
actually just gonna move this out of the
way and what I'm gonna do here is on my
wall turning this is a great thing about
Java by the way you can do anything you
want so basically what I want to do I'm
gonna set let's make him move right for
example so I'm going to set X home we
can make him move down Y a plus plus hit
ctrl s look at that he's moving down
he's not actually being animated though
for some reason that's moving back help
why I - - hit control s and look at that
that's like him move him down and make
him stationary so walking where are we
setting that okay we're setting it here
so that should be updating the sprite
but it's not for some reason that's kind
of weird
let's um let's make him stop here okay
good that was a clutch stopping that
let's see so to make him so animated
sprite here should be updating if he's
walking so if X I Y does not equal zero
walking sir so walking should be true
right let's just make sure that um it is
true by printing and walking out here so
if I make this okay so you can see he is
walking now the way that we make these
animated sprites
how we doing that so we're making them
from a sprite sheet here and we're
setting the length to be
- fine mm-hmm
that's quite bizarre isn't it because he
should be um a willful player we wear
how to do this stuff they're doing I
think this stuff is uh should be gone
yeah he's still okay good um right so
yeah okay okay I think um my walking is
true though we had okay let's um and I
met him on the x-axis and see what that
gives us
oh that doesn't even flip a sprite what
why
that's weird isn't it and most part is
said to run oh hang on we forgot to set
the sprite to be equal to a meta sprite
whoops my bad okay so you can see here
in player that somewhere I think it's
over yeah yeah we set sprite equal to
animated sprite gets bright anims
brighter gets bright make sure you copy
and paste that into over here because
ass fried is not changing at all so we
save that you can see it's actually
pointing in the right direction here if
we save that and make it XA minus minus
you can see that he is animated here and
it looks bad because um I must have I
must not have aligned this price
correctly okay that seems to work so
that's minus minus there and ended after
why a yeah he's animated okay sweat so
that is how we animate our AI character
this tutorial was probably a bit longer
than usual probably could have been
shorter but it did take a bit of time to
solve a few issues so I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit like button 200
likes equals one video per day 300 likes
equals two videos per day I'll see you
guys next time good bye
you